the economy itself is not always a
sufficient clue you know to keep the
European uh to keep Europe together you
know then we would not have had a brexit
for example
um but if it's not money and economies
what does work as a good glue for Europe
and keep can keep the European countries
together
I totally agree with you
um
first I think it's
history and culture
and when when you look at our on isary
and how the European Union was made and
why we decided to do so it's after the
second world war big drama I mean we
almost killed ourselves
because of during the second World War
and I think this generation the
generation of our founding fathers at I
take your own formula but this glue
it was
never ever I don't want to see that
again
and they were sure that we had something
to do together because
our humanism our very special
relationship with
freedom
and at the same time our social model
which is quite unique balance
was some things I wanted to preserve and
they decided to put together
steel and coal
what we needed to fight against each
other during the past decade so as I
said in order to be sure
let's merge on that and an economy and
industry was was not the purpose and the
actual blue
it was just a tool because we wanted to
be sure of that so I would say the first
concern is about history culture
feelings emotions
the second is about I mean precisely
politics
controversies permanent discussions
because we have this culture in this
common history
and this is for me
by Nature I consider it as more
important than economy but I think we
are entering in in these times where
geopolitics precisely will probably
frame and decide on geoeconomics
this is a very new moment
and beyond that and this is what makes
us come in our values